[Musique]
pour
on sera tous ne bougeait plus vous êtes
bien d'un point de vue l'émission où
l'on débat des sujets les plus
intéressants de l'actualité nous allons
le faire ce soir avec gabriel cluzel
bonsoir vous êtes rédactrice en chef du
site boulevard voltaire vous êtes aussi
essayiste et votre dernier livre
enraciné nous sommes tous d héritier a
été publiée aux éditions arte edge puis
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir aussi
gilles smadja bonsoir vous diriger le
cabinet du maire divers gauche de
nanterre et vous êtes un ancien
journaliste au quotidien l'humanité
commençons par parler si vous le voulez
bien de ces propositions de lois
nombreuses en a quatre qui propose de
légiférer sur ce qu'on appelle la fin de
vie pour faire court
ces propositions visent à autoriser
l'euthanasie c'est à dire de pouvoir
autoriser une assistance médicale active
à mourir c'est à dire concrètement
l'injection d'un produit qui va faire
mourir la personne quand elle est à la
fois majeur capable en phase avancée ou
terminale d'une affection grave et
incurable provoquant une douleur
physique ou une souffrance psychique
insupportable je le disais l'une de ses
propositions de loi déposé par la
sénatrice marie pierre de la gontrie va
être débattue demain au sénat le
président du sénat gérard larcher n'est
pas trop chaud écoutez sa réaction ce
matin à france inter la culture des
soins palliatifs qui pas encore
totalement entré à l'hôpital
je pense que nous devons nous appuyer
sur la loi claisse leonetti c'est
vraiment méchant à plus loin à plus loin
que ça c'est votre vision des joncs non
bombay tri-zone ont le temps laissons la
culture des soins palliatifs mais je dis
tout ça avec eux mes convictions
cluzel elles sont pas d'origine
gouvernementale ces propositions de loi
pourquoi ce qu'elle arrive maintenant à
votre avis est-ce qu'il ya un besoin non
plus précisément c'est quand même assez
surprenant est paradoxal au moment où
finalement tout les les forces en france
sont mobilisés pour préserver la vie des
deux de nos aînés ceux qui sont dans les
ehpad ceux qui sont parfois malades et
même avec une rhétorique qui parle de
vie coûte que coûte parfois même en
imposant des des commentaires des
souffrances à toute la société qui exige
des sacrifices on on a on arrêt on a
comment dire mis en avant le prix de la
vie d'ailleurs c'est tout à l'honneur de
la gestion de cette crise c'est à dire
qu'on se dit que la vie est sacrée il
faut la préserver quitte à sacrifier la
vie économique
on dit même que encore une fois ça peut
passer par certaines souffrances qu y
compris pour les intéressés on a vu que
les plaids en ehpad les résidents ou
était comment dire ont fait l'objet de
l'objet de mesures de confinement et
cédera donc ça exigeaient aussi des
activités leur part et aujourd'hui on
veut nous expliquer que finalement ils
l'euthanasie serait une bonne chose donc
c'est vrai que c'est spécialement
illisible par ce temps de crise par
ailleurs c'est un peu curieux alors que
quand on est dans une crise
conjoncturelle de prendre des décisions
structurelles c'est à dire que quand la
maison brûle et bien on va pas prendre
les grandes décisions de vie parce
qu'évidemment nous tous nos capacités de
discernement sont sont altérées donc on
a du mal à comprendre la logique sauf à
imaginer deux choses que les élections
approchent et qu'il faut envoyer un
certain nombre de signaux ou que
précisément ces conditions un peu
altérée de de discernement font qu'il y
aura peut-être moins d'opposition pour
passer quelque chose qui ressemble quand
même à un serpent de mer depuis de
nombreuses années voilà il faut préciser
que la quatre pays
dans l'union européenne ou en europe en
tout cas puisque il ya la suisse
également qui autorise l'euthanasie
notamment le portugal est par une
décision récente votre point de vue six
matches à ce que vous aussi vous voyez
un paradoxe dans ce moment où on lutte
plus tôt pour sauver des vies de de
promouvoir l'euthanasie c'est assez
étonnant
cet emballement parlementaires au moment
où on est confronté d'abord à une
pandémie qui quand même pèse de plus en
plus lourd lourdement sur sur la société
sur les populations sur notre économie
sur notre moral
je trouve quand même assez à contre
temps on va dire est un peu d'aidé
décalé et voilà pas très opportun tout
d'un coup de vouloir absolument faire
revenir sur le devant de la scène
parlementaire un texte de loi bon qui
aurait pu venir il ya longtemps que
pourrait venir demain pourquoi là
maintenant enfin ça c'est assez c'est
assez étonnant cela dit faut pas que la
question du timing ne nous empêche de
parler du fond d'eux empêche de parler
du fond et c'est vrai que bon sur le
fond d'abord moi je crois que peut-être
qu'on peut admettre l'idée qu'on n'a pas
forcément de certitudes sur un sujet
comme celui là
d'une part et peut-être on peut aussi
admettre l'idée que ça va au delà des
clivages politiques traditionnels que
j'ai personnellement je pense qu'il n'y
a pas une vision de gauche ou une vision
de droite de la question de l'euthanasie
et du suicide assisté médicalement je le
crois profondément
et donc je suis souvent partagés d'abord
je pense que la loi existante est une
bonne loi la loi claisse leonello nous
laisse quelques elle avait été à
l'époque voté à l'unanimité à lui et qui
permet quand même
l'utilisation de la sédation dans
certaines conditions enfin on va pas
développer mais en tout cas le permet
l'offre un certain nombre de
possibilités qui répondent aux problèmes
posés peut-être faut-il l'appliquer
réellement peut-être que
voilà peut-être aussi faut-il voir
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple il y à un
nombre très insuffisant de lits dédiés
aux soins palliatifs dans les hôpitaux
que les établissements spécialisés dans
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie et
dans les soins palliatifs sont
malheureusement peu nombreux
donc voilà après je ne fuis pas le débat
sur faut-il faut-il ou pas aller plus
loin
voilà un bon jeu encore une fois je je
revendique de ne pas avoir de certitudes
définitive sur les questions d avril qu
elle je vous livre les commentaires de
nos internautes d'abord la question que
nous posons sur twitter faut-il
légaliser l'euthanasie en france et
c'est oui à 74% alors on rappelle que ce
n'est pas un sondage mais le point de
vue des gens qui sont en train de nous
regarder
que ce soit sur le site du figaro sur
l'application ou sur youtube
sylvie nous dit par exemple en 2021 on
laisse encore des gens souffrir
bravo au portugal qui vient de légaliser
lilas parce que notre corps c'est notre
choix nous devrions avoir le droit de
partir sans souffrir
et puis caroline sur youtube qui elle en
revanche considère que la loi leonetti
est très bien faite et permet de ne pas
mourir dans la souffrance
personne n'a le droit de donner le shoot
ultime
on entendait les les les interrogations
de gilles smadja est-ce que vous avez
les mêmes qu'abriel que celle sur ce
sujet se méfier si je peux me permettre
sans mettre en cause les sondages sur le
sujet mais ceux qui militent pour cette
cause là c'est en général extrêmement
mobilisés et relais très vite le le
sondage est le wild ou qu'il vienne
moi je crois que sur cette question là
il faut avoir une grande méfiance de la
rhétorique est utilisé évidemment
personne n'a envie de souffrir personne
n'a envie de voir ses parents souffrir
et vous avez tout à fait raison de pas
d'évoquer la question des soins
palliatifs parce qu'en réalité on sait
et les médecins en témoignent que
lorsque les gens demandent à mourir
déjà ce n'est pas une demande continuent
généralement ça va et ça vient et ses
fonctions des souffrances qu'ils
ressentent et c'est parfois un appel à
l'aide
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est dit
et répété par les soignants donc la
question des soins palliatifs et des
investissements qu'il faut faire dans
les soins palliatifs est essentiel et je
voudrais pas que la notion d'humanité et
de dignité soient préemptées par les
militant de l'euthanasie moi je me méfie
toujours de de la politique du verbe
parce que je nous il ya des gens qui
vont jusqu'au bout du chemin sans être
d'asie et qui meurt très dignement bien
au contraire je refuse que ce ce mot
soit confisquée par ailleurs croit que
cette crise du duc au vide nous donne
l'expérience nous donne de leçons la
première c'est qu'il faut un principe de
précaution c'est à dire ne pas se lancer
il faut être extrêmement vigilant donc
ne pas décider de loi qui seront en fait
la politique du pied dans la porte
c'est à dire que on commence avec des
ddd loi extrêmement restrictives avec
des exemples très emblématique je
reviendrai pas sur la sphère vincent
lambert mais c'est généralement comme ça
qui arrive les lois sociétal il ya
toujours un un premier cas qui qui
paraît assez effrayant et qui suscite
l'émotion et puis c'est ainsi qu'on met
le pied dans la porte pour une loi qui
ensuite va être une boîte de pandore et
je crois que cette crise nous a appris
aussi à regarder ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays il se trouve que nous
avons il ya le recul des autres pays par
exemple la belgique et les pays bas et
qui montre qu'on a assisté à une dérive
extrêmement inquiétante de temps avec ce
facteur psychologique extrêmement
subjective qui inclut un petit peu tout
et n'importe quoi qu'est-ce que une
souffrance insupportable sur le plan
psychologique
on voit qu aux pays bas et en belgique
ce sont maintenant des enfants qui sont
est anase y est et avec en plus cette
rhétorique extrêmement contradictoires
qui consiste à dire que par exemple la
matière de soins psychologiques
quand quelqu'un est dépressif hisser sa
volonté il demande à se suicider mais on
sait très bien que quand quelqu'un sur
le plan psychologique est fragile et
bien sa décision par définition est
altérée donc l'une demandé de prendre la
décision de se suicider ça paraît
passablement
incohérent quoi qu'il en soit je crois
qu'il est extrêmement important de
regarder tout ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins et de et de réfléchir et de
privilégier la vie puisque c'est ce qui
le choix qui a été fait ces derniers
mois
la vie quoi qu'il en coûte pour prendre
un un slogan qui était plutôt ico est
d'ordre économique dans cette crise du
coc vide et privilégions les soins
palliatifs parce que effectivement
apaiser la souffrance c'est absolument
indispensable
oui mais je pense que comment dire je
vous ai fait part de mon incertitudes de
mes doutes parce que quand j'écoute les
partisans d'une évolution de la loi
pour aller plus loin ils ont quand même
des arguments convaincants
je ne parle pas des extrémistes je ne
parle pas des cas que vous citez qui
sont absolument inacceptables
d'euthanasie d'enfants belgique aux pays
bas
bon je ne parle pas de ça mais c'est
vrai que par exemple sur le principe de
la libre disposition de sa personne de
sa personne et sur le fait qu' on ne
peut pas simplement les laisser
l'argument de la nature opérer parce que
les c'est l'argument de la nature
c'est un peu ce qui avait été opposé
rappelez-vous à madame veille quand elle
avait présenté sa loi pour sortir le
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
de la clandestinité est tout simplement
légaliser voilà un acte médical
on lui avait opposé cet argument de la
nature et donc on voit bien que cet
argument de la nature il a il a l'idée
qu'il faut accepter voilà la mort
naturelle et quoiqu'ils au couac
quoi qu'il en soit que quelle que soit
la situation le contexte ça c'est un as
et un argument je pense qui est qui a
trouvé ses limites quand là quand la
souffrance espinosa je crois qu'il
disait que quand quand la souffrance
quand le corps ne peut plus penser
autrement que par la souffrance c'est
lui qui vous domine et non plus vous qui
le kill qui le dominaient et donc à
partir de là je pense qu'on peut
entendre
l'idée que la première dès le premier
des principes qu'il faudrait réaffirmé
si une évolution de la loi doit
intervenir
c'est effectivement la liberté la
liberté du choix individuel c'est à dire
ne rien imposé à personne ne
y'en imposer à personne donc quand
j'écoute ce point de vue là je me dis
c'est pas tout à fait faux mais en même
temps oui pour une fois je vais dire en
même temps quand j'écoute par exemple le
point de vue de deux médecins deux
soignants qui me disent mais nous on a
pas on est là pour soigner on n'est pas
là pour tuer et on ne compte pas quand
on prête le serment d'hippocrate
c'est ce que l'on dit d'ailleurs et donc
ça part et ça leur paraît totalement
contraire à tout ce pour quoi ils ont
été formés à tous au sens même de leur
de leur métier de leurs engagements et
donc du coup je suis aussi sensible à
cet argument
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que je
n'ai pas de certitudes dans ce domaine
il faut quand même observer une chose
c'est que les pays le nombre de pays qui
aujourd'hui évolué dans leur législation
de manière radicale il y en a quand même
très peu en europe il y en a peu vous
l'avez rappelé il y en a quatre et à
l'extérieur de l'europe il y à quelques
états américains il ya cinq états
américains au total sur heureuse 51 et
il y à la corée je crois de mémoire la
corée du sud le canada
je vous donne des d'autres réactions de
nos internautes le débat est très très
riche et très nourris merci d'y
participer
nathan 770 que cet argument assez assez
fort peut-être même assez brutal si vous
légaliser l'euthanasie sous peu les
enfants turon leurs parents pour hériter
et puis au contraire karine sur youtube
pinault dit chacun le droit de mourir
dans la dignité pour les pays qui l'ont
mise en pratique il ya tout un protocole
avant et apparemment tout se passe bien
like heures sur youtube le problème
c'est lorsqu'une personne n'a plus toute
sa tête comment savoir ce qu'elle
déciderait il aurait peut-être des abus
sinon une personne sensée devrait avoir
le droit de décider
et puis
qu'est ce que je vous ai déjà donné la
position de caroline je ne me souviens
plus qui nous dit sur youtube la loi
léonetti très bien fait
elle permet de ne pas mourir dans la
souffrance personne n'a le droit de
donner le shoot ultime
je vous le disais il ya quatre
propositions de lois qui sont déposés
actuellement et ce qui est rarissime
elles elles sont très proches les unes
des autres alors qu'elles proviennent de
gens de parties très différent puisque
il ya une députée les républicains qui a
déposé deux propositions
une sénatrice socialiste marie-pierre de
la gontrie un député marcheurs jean
louis touraine un autre socialiste
olivier falorni
on sait que l'euthanasie est un est un
combat porté par la franc maçonnerie
l'un des militants de cette cause
jean-louis tourenne le parlementaire en
marche d'ailleurs ne cache pas son
appartenance est ce que ça peut
expliquer que y ait des gens de tous les
partis qui soit favorable à cette mesure
gabriel cluzel selon secret de
polichinelle en effet un certain nombre
de lois sociétal on peut penser celle
qui est actuellement qui fait débat sur
la pma a été également promue par un
certain nombre de l'offre amazon qui le
disent ouvertement du reste et ont fait
que certaines logent accueil ddd comment
dire d'un parmi les parmi ses membres
des gens qui peuvent être à droite ou à
gauche ce qui explique du reste le les
avancées
sociétal surprenantes sont des régimes
qu'on pourrait imaginer un peu par
réflexe pavlovien ou pour imaginer de
droite dont conservateur ce qu'il ya
c'est que c'est cependant moins facile
peut-être faut néanmoins pour des gens
de droite de porter ces projets là ils
le savent parce que leur électorat
les sanctionnera sans doute durement
peut-être plus durement que des même pas
du tout durement pour les et pour les
hommes politiques dignes de gauche qui
au contraire sont attendus sur ces
points là par leurs électeurs c'est ce
qui fait toute la différence mais en
effet on voit bien que cela excellent à
transcender les points de vue politiques
moi simplement pour vous répondre sur le
sur le je vous laisse après sur les
larges connaissances mais ce qui me ce
qui me ce qui me chagrine dans votre
démonstration sur le fait de disposer de
sa propre vie c'est que si je suis votre
rhétorique
quand il y à des des suicides par
exemple par nouader des pompiers qui
récupère des gens qui se sont jetés dans
l'eau et on en voit tous les jours dans
la presse quotidienne régionale on porte
même au pinacle des jeunes qui sont
allés récupérer
donc il aurait fallu qu'il a redit qu'il
les laisse partir leur disant au revoir
d'un petit signe de la main
non évidemment que leur portent secours
de masse très moyen très peu les jambes
a oui et pourtant c'était leur choix en
muscles royer d'exemple si ça vous
attend non mais très mauvais exemple
très mauvais exemple le pompier qui voit
quelqu'un se noyait il va il semble
devoir c'est d'aller le sauver
même si là je vais le passer parce que
mais non mais c'est sa volonté peut-être
dans l'instant à fait d'accord ça
passait de main non ça n'a rien à voir
sinon c est votre exemple et son
influence sur moi je me donnerai à la
main
de la franc-maçonnerie derrière cet
emballement pas masquer ponctuellement
un complot ce doit être un projet par
les roches mende je crois que je je vous
redis alors là c'est une conviction
profonde c'est le genre de débat de
société sur lesquels pour moi il n'y a
pas de point de vue de droite et de
points de vue de gauche il n'y a pas un
point de vue progressiste ou
conservateurs voilà je pense que c'est
quelque chose de plus intime de plus et
qu'on peut être partagée on peut pousser
les deux points de vue voilà je crois
que c'est plus ça et donc vous trouverez
à droite des gens qui sont farouchement
partisan de l'évolution de la loi
actuelle est il qu'ils sont pour
l'euthanasie pour la légalisation et
vous trouverez à gauche des gens qui
sont totalement opposés donc franchement
ces jeux je pense que ça n'est pas tout
à fait le un recoupement idéologiques
traditionnels merci alors on va voir
s'il ya des recoupements idéologique sur
le second sujet de notre débat la ville
de lyon va mettre en place un budget
genre et alors qu'est ce qu'un truc du
genre et je vais vous expliquer ça en
quelques mots je vais essayer en tout
cas l'idée c'est que c'est de s'assurer
que l'argent qui est dépensé par une
municipalité profite bien autant aux
hommes qu'aux femmes vous savez que il y
à une nouvelle majorité à lyon depuis
les élections municipales et que le
maire est désormais un écologiste c'est
grégory douce et alors l'adjointe qui
est en charge de ce sujet donne donne un
exemple dans les cours d'école elles
sont généralement goudronnée pour
permettre les jeux de ballons et qui
joue et ben ce sont les petits garçons
et les petites filles du coup ce sont
sur les côtés
donc il faut imaginer des cours de
récréation qui puisse faire plaisir à
tout le monde en organisant par exemple
les activités de jardinage
il semblerait donc que ce soit une
activité plutôt féminine pourquoi pas j
smadja vous vous êtes l'un des
principaux dirigeants d'une grande ville
celle de nantes est qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette idée budget genre et ça
n'existe pas d'abord c'est pas permis
c'est interdit par le code général des
collectivités territoriales c'est
impossible d'être sûr que l'idée de
présenter un budget qui serait de dire
voilà ce que l'on fait pour les femmes
et voilà ce que l'on fait pour les
hommes
ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
possible ça serait complet donc c'est
que de la com je pense que c'est un
habillage de communication pour tout
simplement dire ce qui se fait dans
d'autres
nombreuses villes mais vraiment c'est à
dire par contre vous avez obligation
c'est une loi de 2012 qui a été
renforcée en 2014
vous avez obligation de veiller à ce que
l'utilisation de l'argent public
l'argent que donnent les communes par
exemple à des associations ou des
actions que mènent les communes par
exemple dans l'activité sportive
périscolaire vous avez le devoir de
veiller à ce que l'argent public ne
contribue pas à aggraver les inégalités
mais au contraire à les réduire mais sur
le fond ça c'est une autre question le
principe de ce2 ce2 ce budget qui par
exemple amènerait aussi à regarder
combien d'hommes et de femmes visite une
exposition pour savoir si l'argent mis
dans la culture et est bien dépensé
mais également qu'elle est le genre d
artistes invités qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la démarche je pense que je
pense qu'il il comment dire non le fait
on fait un an terme un certain nombre de
choses par exemple on regarde
parmi les enfants dans l'est qui vont
dans les centres de vacances dans les
colonies de vacances on regarde quelle
est la proportion de filles et de
garçons
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que pendant toute une période
et bien il y avait une disproportion
totale vous aviez 70 à 80 % de garçons
et seulement 20 à 30% et pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce qu'il y
avait pendant longtemps il y avait
beaucoup plus de demandes que de places
disponibles et donc on dit par exemple
une famille qui veut envoyer ses deux
enfants en centres de vacances on lui
dit écoute est désolé mais il faut il
faut en choisir un des deux ça peut pas
être les deux parce qu'il ya trop de
demandes et devinez qui elle choisit en
général de mettre au centre de vacances
et le garçon sait comme c'est un peu
plus turbulents je sais pas en tout cas
le résultat c'est qu'on a constatée et
donc si vous voulez la décision a été
prise de corriger cette inégalité en
veillant à ce qu'il y ait davantage de
jeunes filles qui puisse aller au centre
de vacances c'est la même chose pour le
par exemple pour le sport si vous quand
vous donnez une subvention à un club de
foot vous avez ans dans le club de foot
une section féminine
une section masculine et bien si vous ne
vais y est pas à ce que cet argent soit
utilisé pour promouvoir le football chez
les filles autant que chez les garçons
vous pouvez être sûr que par exemple les
créneaux lee l'utilisation des terrains
va être totalement monopolisé par par
les garçons donc il il faut mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec un budget en genre et
sanaa ça n'a aucun sens un budget
j'avais tout simplement parce que le
budget il s'adresse à toute la
population ne s'adresse pas c'est le
thème catégorie gabriel quand on a vu
cette information on se dit que ça
allait vous plaire non encore le droit
de dire j'aime pas jouer au foot et on
pourrait imposer de jouer au foot
enfants parce qu'il fallait absolument
que les filles je vous souhaitez qu'on
leur réserve un budget pour le faire sa
mort est profondément soul et si vous me
promettez cette expression un peu
inquiète beaucoup toujours le psy qui
n'aime pas mais c'est pas hasard si
effectivement les cours de récréation
sera occupé par par les garçons dans ce
registre
non je crois que j'ai de ce mot fait
partie des mots camou locle à kiki qui
sont bien qui habille un peu de façon un
peu précieuse 1 1 mais comme on dit une
politique de la ville alors qu'ils
auraient pu mettre là aussi un budget
genre et inclusif solidaire et résignant
ça aurait été encore plus joli grain et
durable a alors les femmes croient
qu'elles ont elles partagent quelque
chose avec les hommes c'est ça c'est
bien partagée celle envie qu'on se moque
pas d'elle les consommez pas leur tête
et en l'occurrence il n'y a pas le sort
d'une seule femme je pense qu'il sera
amélioré par ce genre de mesure en
france qui serait intéressant pour les
femmes mais je ne le vois pas sur cette
ligne là au vu de sa communication le
maire de lyon sur les récents incidents
un acte avant une communication un petit
peu bisous
c'est à dire ce qui est intéressant pour
les femmes parce que c'est vrai que les
caractéristiques des femmes c'est que
physiquement elles ont dû elles ont du
mal dans un univers où la sécurité n'est
pas assurée c'est à dire qu'on apporte
du moment où où la loi de la jungle
revient dans un dans un univers urbain
les premières victimes
ce sont les femmes évidemment parce que
s'il ya une inégalité intellectuelle
absolue sur le plan physique il ya des
réalités biologiques qui font qu'elles
sont plus facilement agresser je pense
que tout où toutes les manifestations
récentes que l'on a pu voir ont l'ont
démontré donc la meilleure façon d'aider
les femmes c'est d'avoir une politique
sécuritaire de la ville en réalité c'est
à dire que la famille font beaucoup de
bruit c'est là-bas jusqu'à
malheureusement par exemple en matière
d'éclairage public
par exemple il ya des communes comme la
nôtre qui ont décidé d'augmenter
l'éclairage public dans certains
secteurs par ce pont que ça soit bien
éclairé d'amendé s'il est intéressant
c'est aussi de mettre les délinquants en
prison de façon qu'ils ne récidivent pas
par exemple
moi j'étais toujours surprise de voir
que royal des ministres de la justice
pourtant femmes elles s'inquiètent elles
ne sont pas du tout attiré par l'aspect
répressif qui pourtant est intéressant
pour assurer l'épanouissement de la
femme dans l'une d'elles dans l'univers
urbain
je dirai aussi que vous voyez anne
hidalgo ben moi je trouve que sa
politique du tout transport en commun
n'est pas favorable pour les femmes le
soir parce que une femme seule elle
prendra volontiers sa voiture parce que
c'est moins facile pour elle de prendre
le transport en commun donc moi moi je
veux bien un affichage genre et comme on
dit mais je ne crois que derrière c'est
essentiellement de la com et dont les
femmes à s'épanouir avec des mesures
pratiques qui lui permettent d'être à
égalité dans l'espace public non mais
c'est une eau attendez je pense qu'il
faut quand on connaît un peu le sujet
c'est bien de le connaître c'est que
c'est une obligation de la loi de qui
date de 2012 qui a été renforcée en 2014
de présenter chaque année devant le
conseil municipal
un rapport qui doit dire en quoi le
budget l'argent que vous dépensez le
budget de la commune contribue à la
lutte contre les inégalités hommes
femmes
c'est une obligation donc vous devez le
faire pour le personnel communal pour
montrer par exemple que dans les postes
dirigeants dans les cadres de la
fonction publique territoriale vous avez
autant de femmes que d'hommes alors que
l'on sait que c'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui
donc voila et vous devez le faire aussi
pour les grandes causes
éthique publique celle qui consomme le
plus de budget c'est à dire la culture
le sport l'éducation tout ce qui est le
périscolaire et c'est donc c'est une
obligation est donc évidemment une
commune en général les communes elles
elles ont envie que les politiques
qu'elle mène eh bien elle soit autant
utile aux garçons qu'aux filles aux
hommes qu'aux femmes
voilà c'est tout ça n'est rien d'autre
que ça quand ils à ce que dit vous ce
que disent les élus de lyon il ya il ya
des dizaines et des dizaines de communes
qui le font déjà depuis longtemps alors
ça n'a pas l'air d'emballer nos
internautes à ce projet budget genre et
pensez vous que ce soit un progrès vous
répondez non à 87% alors sur vous
commentez en revanche là c'est plus plus
discutés
aaron sur youtube nous dit un budget qui
a pour objectif de faire respecter la
parité entre hommes et femmes est une
bonne chose sur le papier il faudra voir
en pratique dans l'application l'utilité
et l'efficacité
jean-marc considère au contraire que
c'est une magnifique preuve de la bêtise
humaine
la question à traiter nous dit marie
kikicé de rééduquer les hommes qui
interdisent aux femmes d'être libre et
puis nicole 06 s'interroge est ce que il
se pose la question de savoir si les
filles veulent faire aussi veulent faire
la même chose que les garçons et puis
une autre c'est absolument attention aux
effets de mode au niveau de l'évolution
sociétale il faut éviter les dogmes par
exemple alors comme on parle de budget
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
j ce matin j'ai été horrifié en voyant
l'étude de contribuables associés qui
est une association qui défend les gens
ici payent des impôts elle sommes assez
nombreux dans ce cas et alors ils ont
fait une étude pour ça qu'elles étaient
les villes où on dépense est le plus
c'est les villes ou en dépenser le moins
alors la ville ou en dépense le moins
c'est à dire le budget la dépense de
fonctionnement par habitant c'est cholet
alors cholet on dépense 703 euros par
habitant est alors parmi les mauvais
élèves
il ya en tête anne hidalgo mais après
tout c'est la capitale de la france et
peut-être à mal et puis derrière y avoue
yann en terre alors comment vous
expliquez ça c'est votre cher
non pas vraiment non je ne pense que pas
vraiment mais si vous voulez comment
j'explique ça parce que les chiffres
sont totalement be
c'est à dire qu'en réalité les chiffres
qui sont donnés on met le budget de
fonctionnement il sauf que l'association
des contribuables qui oublie juste
oublié de dire que dans ce budget de
vente dans ses dépenses de
fonctionnement
il y aller 22 millions d'euros qui nous
sont prélevés immédiatement pour
alimenter les caisses de solidarité pour
d'autres communes 22 millions d'euros et
il y aller quel et 50 millions d'euros
que nous qui sont immédiatement prélevés
pour aller dans les caisses de la
métropole du grand paris alors en
réalité quand vous ramener aux as qui
reste réellement dans les caisses de la
commune de nanterre pour les habitants
de nanterre on est à 1900 euros par
habitant et non pas au 2410 jette dans
l'eau de la fontaine et ses bruits
d'oiseaux nabawi parce que nanterre est
une ville qui a traditionnellement eu
beaucoup d'entreprises voilà donc c'est
une ville qui c'est qui s'est développée
il ya cent mille emplois il ya plus
d'emplois que d'entre eux que
d'habitants à nanterre donc oui nanterre
ben voila mais c'est de moins en moins
vrai et ça diminue l'état pour vous
donner un seul exemple il ya chaque
commune reçoit une dotation de l'état
ça s'appelle dotation de global de
fonctionne dotation de fonctionnement
merci par l'état parce que il ya plein
de mission que les communes font pour le
compte de l'état par exemple délivrer
les passeports les cartes d'identité on
le fait pour le compte de l'état et donc
l'état compensera par des dotations il y
a seulement 12 ans il ya douze ans
l'état versé à la commune de nanterre 18
millions d'euros 18 millions d'euros
cette année zéro il n'y a plus rien plus
un euro qui vient de l'état dans le
budget de la ville de nanterre voilà
c'est pour vous dire dans quelle
trajectoire on est aujourd'hui donc
malheureusement non leur l'heure n'est
pas du tout à un gaspillage ou non
contraire chaque année le principal
problème qui est posé à chaque commune
aujourd'hui au début c'est comment on va
faire pour boucler le budget cette année
c'est ça le problème qui est posé mais
voilà cela pour ça qu'on est ravie de
vous avoir parce que vous nous parlez de
choses très concrètes mais aussi ravis
d'accueillir l'accusé donc merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir suivi
cette émission merci
à vous chers internautes de nous restait
fidèle et surtout revenez demain
bonsoir
[Musique]